simplest
measure of where we are in a language is
how many words we know
[Music]
hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about language learning and today
i'm going to talk about vocabulary
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe you can click on the
bell for notifications
um and come and join me at link and
speaking of link i'm going to talk a
little bit about my vocabulary
at link i'm going to do some analysis of
my vocabulary
because i believe that the the
fundamental the simplest i called it
like back 15 years ago i called this
sort of the gordian knot
simplest
measure of where we are in a language
is how many words we know
and i mean passively i mean recognizing
words in a context i don't mean
necessarily being able to use them
because that develops slowly and it
develops as we have the opportunity or
the need to use the language but we need
to have this passive vocabulary to build
up our familiarity with the language so
that we can access interesting content
read interesting content watch movies
uh engage with people and interesting
conversations we need the passive
vocabulary so that's what i measure
so i decided to have a look at where i
stood
uh on link
first of all a quick review of my stats
for this past week
uh you'll see that i open this up here
that i added 500 new known words
i created 652 links that's to say i met
words that i didn't know
and i added them to my database
of the links
in the known words area 447
i actually learned like i moved them to
known
uh and others are words that i simply
didn't look up because
i could tell what they meant because i
have known i have learned other words
that are very very similar could be
different forms of the of the word so
that's my status for the week if i now
look at the sort of my all-time status
or statistics
you'll see that i have 19 211 known
words again words that i know passively
i can't use 19 000 words in arabic
i struggle when i speak with my tutor as
you're going to see when i do my exit
video with my tutor
next week and we might even make that a
live stream or at any rate i will uh you
know make a video which will be
available
on youtube
however i do have 19 000 passively known
words but i have 57 000 links words that
i have words and phrases that i have
saved
so i really know a small subset
of all the words that i have saved
i know a third of them
so there's two thirds that i've met
looked up and no longer know what they
mean
uh so i i wanted to do a little more
analysis of this
so what i did was uh i sort of went into
the vocab section
and
there uh you know you initially you look
at
if you look at the status it has every
one of the four or the five statuses
are ticked off so the total number of
vocabulary that i have saved the total
number of my
created links
is 57 56 970. okay
now
i can go and change the parameters
so let's for example say that i go into
my a vocab section
and i choose only status one so i tick
the others i get rid of the others i'm
only going to look at status one words
well it shows me here
that 36
500 of my 57 000 saved links i hope i'm
not confusing you
but the bulk of the words that i have
met and looked up in a dictionary are
still status one in other words
new so
those are words that haven't shown up
again
or i don't remember them or whatever
so
so i went into my status one words
and found that actually where there were
a lot of words there that i actually
knew or i had some familiarity with so i
went into my list and started upgrading
them to status 2 or status 3 or even
known
now that's not a tremendously useful
thing to do in a way
because if our if there are words there
that i know
and if they show up again you know i
have an opportunity while i'm in the
lesson page
to upgrade them to move them to status 2
or status 3 or make them known so to do
this you know in a concentrated fashion
in the vocab section you know you got a
way that versus
being in a lesson new material the
language you're hearing it you're
reading it should you be doing that or
should you be working with your
vocabulary list so this is a question we
all have to decide but
in a way it's fun to do this because
it's a different kind of activity
uh
the other thing of course is in most
languages if you organize or if you
list them
in where it says sort by
if you list them alphabetically and
that's going to mean different things in
different languages but you're going to
end up getting four or five forms of the
same word or four or five words that
have the same starting component and
that can be very helpful in terms of
solidifying your grasp of the word so
it's i i kind of enjoy spending some
time on my lists
uh now what's interesting is
if i look at the distribution
of my uh vocabulary that is of my saved
links there's 57 000 of them
uh 64
are status one the overwhelming majority
uh
status four and five that is words that
i've now moved to known is the lex next
largest group
and there are very few in status 2 and
status 3. now there are a number of
reasons for this a lot of people and i
myself included
i'm not sure what's the purpose of
status 2 in status 3 like either i know
it or i don't know it but lately i kind
of changed my attitude and i said i
should be moving more to three because
whatever is in status three
those are words that i i'm not entirely
sure of but i'm getting close to where i
think i can recognize them and so i'm
now much more inclined whether with a
list or while i'm doing a text i'm more
inclined to move words up in status
manually to two and eventually to get to
three because what i do now from time to
time i go in there to status three words
and i move to known
the ones that i now feel i know
bearing in mind the sum will move back
in status because a couple of weeks
later now you don't know the word that's
fine the statistics adjust and it's not
important
now the point is
that um
you know why do this
well one thing is when you go to select
your lessons here we have 14
uh new words so that's a useful
number it tells you how difficult this
is going to be
so uh you know
the status you know obviously
and so this page looks like this right
so i got a bunch of blue words that i
can look up some of which i may even
know and i might move them to status
four or one or known right away or i've
always got the opportunity to move them
up in status as i read
so so then the question is so you're
going to move them up to status 3 in
order to go in there and pick up
whatever words you think you know
to bump up your statistics
why do that
you know if those words let's say
there's a bunch of words that you know
buried in your status one buried in the
sort of words that are new and they have
it hasn't shown up but you've seen other
words similar to that so that these
words now are in fact known so
if i then go in there find them
make them known it makes my statistics
look better however
probably if i kept reading and listening
i would eventually find those so you
know it doesn't because i move them to
known doesn't make them known either
they're known or they're not known so if
my statistics are saying that i know
nineteen thousand words and there's
another thousand words
buried in number one or two or three
in reality it doesn't matter but it is
fun
and it is fun to go through the lists
and look for the words you know or you
think you're getting closer to knowing
while you're doing that you're comparing
them to words that are similar
it's a bit of a reminder
and and if you have a specific task like
moving them from one to two from two to
three from three to known it gives you
another very sort of specific practical
thing you can do
that makes it more interesting
to go through the lists so that it's not
just i'm trying to i want to remember
that i want to remember this word no the
task is moving them a status so you are
being exposed to them again you're doing
this specific you know task you're not
telling yourself i must learn this i
must learn this because that's not very
effective
so i just thought i would pass this on
as something that i've been
experimenting with
um and uh be interested in hearing your
comments
a little bit confusing no doubt bye for
now
[Music]